matrix polynomial concentration and
shared lower bounds for blanket cakes
and dragoo will begin
thanks prasad
thanks for inviting me here
and i'm also really glad that there's a
lot of horizontal space because i can
finally fit the title of the talk on the
board
of the paper the paper title is
association schemes
non-communicated polynomial
concentration
and laser lower bounds for planted
clique
and i'll talk about each of these pieces
these two will be our tools to solve
this problem
okay but the tools itself the way we use
it and
the things we develop there might be
useful elsewhere
so let me start with this classical
question
and
the main object of study here
is
a random graph drawn from
the distribution gm half
we have a graph drawn from g and half
and we are really interested in
our just click
how big is the largest click in g and
it's an easy exercise
to show that
the largest stake is roughly
exactly something like this
two times log n plus some little of one
terms
and
what we would like to understand is if
we can
find
large clicks
so can we find large cliques from random
graphs drawn from g and half
and the simple algorithm which is where
you basically just count the degrees and
so on
says that we can find clicks
of size
talk to basin
login base 2 okay
and
this problem has received a lot of
attention and in fact
carp
in 76
asked if
and find a clique of size
1 plus epsilon times log n
can you find a clique of size 1.1 times
log n base 2 for a random graph with
high probability in polynomial running
time
and this has been around for a long time
we haven't made much progress on this
but what can we say about it
well there is a simple algorithm which
runs in quasi-polynomial time you just
look at all possible login sizes and
that gives you an algorithm
so can solve
n to the o of log n time
and beating this has been a challenge
it's also been uh
kind of you posited as a hard
computational problem used for building
certain groups of crypto systems and so
on and so forth
and because this problem has been so
hard
a very nice
relaxation of the problem which is
interesting by itself was suggested by
independently by jerome
kuchera
there was the relaxation
so we start with the random graph as
here but we now plant a big clique
inside the graph
so this is the planted clique problem
so you have a parameter t which is
typically
much bigger than log n
and
let me write it down
we are given a graph g
from g n half let me just denote it as g
and half t
meaning you just draw a graph from
dn half
and then
add a click
the largest clique in these graphs will
vary with very high probability be
exactly t
and the question is can you
find large clicks now
ideally you would just like to find the
planted clique but even beating uh
even just finding large cliques
is actually hard i mean we don't know
how to do that
so what do we know about this problem
uh
kuchera himself
showed that
you can solve the problem if t is
roughly
square root and log n
is bigger than square root n log n then
you can just count the degrees and one
of the vertices has such large degrees
so you can find the click
and
alone
krivalevich
budaka
98 get a spectral algorithm
which solves the problem for t which is
omega of root n
and
this has been the state of affairs
since
and the main challenge has been to break
the root and barrier can you find a
large clique if i plant a clique of size
n to the 0.49 0.499 or anything like
that where you beat the square root n by
an exponent
and once again this has received a lot
of attention
and we don't know much in terms of
positive results but there's been a lot
of work and trying to understand
what algorithms what classes of
algorithms can or cannot solve this
problem
so this is in the context of lower
bounds for this problem
so
this is average case so you have to be
so
we don't have as nice a theory for
average case our problems in terms of
reductions and so on
but uh
in some sense it stands its own league i
think because of this end to the login
trivial algorithm so the scale is
different
yeah
right right right and in fact i think
this problem is kind of uh
it's not just a standalone problem of
curiosity
into the
one over a hundred and this is
a
random gn one-half
so there are no reductions like that
that i know of uh
and i think getting such deductions or
formulating the right conjectures would
be
uh
would be great because the current
techniques don't allow for that um
theory would be nice like something like
that would be great
i think [ __ ] has some reductions along
those lines but not for this problem
from some other problems
so what we'll study here is lower bounds
for this problem
in
restricted computational models but
these restrictions are themselves quite
natural in the setting we are looking at
so there is even effort to
beat the constant in front of the water
so there you're really interested in
like linear time versus polynomial time
so
what they show is i can solve the
problem for t is omega of
t is epsilon times root n
in time n to the o of epsilon i think
oh sorry
so you can keep improving this but you
then you lose in the polynomial timeline
so lower bounds
so the first lower bond was actually
from the paper of jerome
that introduced this problem
so he showed that uh
mcmc algorithms a broad class of mcmc
algorithms that he formally defines but
i don't want to go into here
cannot
solve
the problem
are
less than root n
this t is n to the 0.49 this cannot
solve the problem these algorithms
cannot solve the problem
and we'll see why root n occurs as a
natural pattern if you when we look at
the proof but uh that's what happens
and does all this algorithm fit within
the um
oh no i don't think so because it's
spectral and it's a different uh
and
tons of positive results there's a very
nice paper of vega and
frog camera
what they actually show is not just that
you can solve this problem but you can
also solve
a stronger problem but still for t is
root n i won't define what the stronger
problem is basically there after adding
this planted clique you can delete some
edges and you can still work
or add some edges
so what they showed is that
the
lower lowest
subscriber
s plus hierarchy
so because it's a commentary
optimization problem one of the most
powerful techniques we have for solving
such questions is
our hierarchies we start with the base
problem formulate it as a
convex optimization problem and then you
consider relaxations of it which come
from the lift and project methods
and what they showed is that
our rounds
of
ls plus
salts
or t which is root n
by two to the r
so i'll
uh be skipping all constant factors but
that's not important for us
and this is what they showed if you look
at our rounds of last lowest driver
hierarchy in the semi-definite version
then you can solve the problem for t
which is roughly square root n by 2 to
the r
and again this matches the lower bound
we had the algorithm we had earlier if
you want to beat root n by polynomial
factor because you have to go up till
r which is some login
and the important thing to keep in mind
which
is that
this can be done
in
n to the o of r time
so if you consider order on relaxation
then you can solve the problem and end
to the o of r9 so i won't define what
this hierarchy is but
we'll consider the i'll define what
strengthening of this hierarchy that
we'll study later on
so that's great but
in a follow-up paper
figure and crop gamma again
sure that this hierarchy which is a very
powerful class of algorithms cannot do
better
so they showed that
ls plus
after r rounds
what
for t which is much less than square
so you you really have to go up to log
and rounds if you want to beat
root n
and
what we'll consider here today is
a much stronger class of semi-definite
relaxations which is the laser hierarchy
and we show an analogous result
there a lower bond for that hierarchy
this is the main theorem of the stock
again i'll define this hierarchy in a
few slides
in a few minutes but
it is the most powerful class of
semi-definite relaxations we know
there are various names of this let me
just write them down
sum of squares
and
cannot solve
for b
which is it's not exactly square root of
10 by 2 to the r
but t which is
so it's an exponent of r squared
so what uh question
so what this means is that
you should actually you have to at least
go up to square root log n rounds if you
want to beat
root n
and the upper bound is still the same so
there's a gap in the lower bound and
upper bound but
it at least says that you cannot get a
polynomial time algorithm just by
looking at laser hierarchy
because there are several algorithms now
we don't need to solve
don't mean end to the order on time
yeah
but
uh
but you could say the same thing for ls
plus then right so
that's a different ball game
so you cannot solve the problem for
if you take r to b oh you're beating
root n uh you want to beat it by n to
the point four nine or something yeah
yeah
uh
i mean
i think you can know
at the moment we still don't have a
longer time
for little or four
yeah you are right
you're right but i think this lower
bound the login is kind of extraneous
the most interesting setting is if you
want to get into the 0.49 it's a it's
somewhat of an artifact of the analysis
i would say
so if i were to venture a guess i would
say the right answer should be this
but some people believe it's true to r
square so
and why is this hierarchy
that
it's a completely i think it's a
completely different uh beast from ls
plus hierarchy
and this has been of considerable
attention in the past few years
because
this hierarchy
is uh
of imminent threat to many central
questions
in a recent work
barack
at all
2012
sure that there exists
and
uh
so we had a class of uh hard instances
for the uniqueness conjecture and
related problems
uh which were hard for ls plus shiraeli
adams plus and all of these
weaker sdp hierarchies but this
hierarchy actually can solve all of
those heart problems or all of those
hard instances can solve
gap instances
for unique games max cut
process cut
and related problems
so this hierarchy is genuinely more
powerful than
ls plus and cheryl adams plus and all
the other hierarchies so coming up with
lower bounds for this hierarchy
is
more of an evidence for the hardness of
the problem i think
so
so let me now talk about how how we
prove this theorem
and i'll just sketch
oh yeah yeah there are there are uh i'll
get to them in a bit but let me just
jump ahead and say that now
so
in terms of lower bounds
so there's a work of grigoria which
introduces positive state and sus
framework from
from there
so this works is very powerful because
it proved lower bonds for the hierarchy
even before it was defined
and
for basically for knapsack
and
random
klm
and some of these results especially
ones for threesat and taylin were
rediscovered by
chernabek in 2008.
and once you have this kind of base
lower bounds you can use these and
combine with known
reductions to get further lower bounds
and this was uh
i think
you'll
tulsiani
used
these
less reductions
to get
lower bonds for
for max clique
and others
so you might ask we already have a lazer
lure bond for max click but the question
but the problem is that well
the problem is that
the lower bound instance here is worst
case so you start with a random three
set and run it through your favorite np
harness reduction you don't understand
what distribution of instances you're
going to get
but we are really interested in natural
distribution like g and half g and half
t and so on
so that's why we kind of have to start
from
in some sense start from scratch we'll
use the techniques but we have to build
cannot use these lower bonds as black
box
so in the remaining
20 minutes let me spend five minutes
here five minutes here and 10 minutes
on how the actual lower bound grows okay
so association schemes uh some most some
of you might have seen this before so
these are classical objects in coding
theory combinatorics and uh
uh
i think coding through in combinatorics
mainly javin studied a lot and
let me here we i'll specifically look at
johnson's king
johnson scheme and
so what johnson scheme is
it is a vector space of matrices with a
certain property
so let me define how uh
what this base is it's a space of
it's a space of matrices and the rows
are indexed by
subsets
of size
are
off
you have an end element set and the rows
are indexed by subsets of size r
and the columns also
by let me just write this as
okay
and you have a function mu
which
from 0 1 to 2 r let's say
two reals
and given this function you can define a
matrix here as follows
so this is mu
we take a specific subset i
and the specific subset j
and the ijth entry
is mu of the size of the union
okay so the ijs entry only depends on
the size of the union but not on the
specific sets
so the space of all these matrices is
the johnson scheme
so these are huge matrices but the
number of free parameters here is very
small you have only two r parameters
and
it could be negative anything
and
because you want a vector space in the
end
and this set of matrix has some really
nice properties and the most important
of them which we will use throughout
is that all made all mu
commute
you can work this out just by some
simple
calculations but this is very important
and if you have a bunch of matrices
which all commute what do we know about
them then you can diagonalize them
simultaneously
and that means there exists a there
exist eigen spaces
there exist some vector spaces which are
simultaneously eigen spaces for all the
matrices in this class
so
and not only that coding theories and
com
and combinatorialists
have characterized completely what these
eigen spaces are
we know
what the eigen spaces are
and because of this there is an analog
at least in philosophy of fourier
transform for this matrices
let me put this in quotes
we can do some kind of fourier transform
for
muse
and we also know
what
eigen values
are
from u
so if you give me a mu i can write some
expressions involving some binomial
coefficients which will tell me exactly
what the eigenvalues are
and finally
this was something new which we had to
kind of
develop somewhat on our own you can also
understand which matrices in this class
are positive semi-definite
and that will be very important for us
this is not a characterization but
uh
it's a very useful way of proving things
for positive semi-definite and so on
and we will use this property and this
property in our analysis
so that's all i'll say about association
schemes
and now let me talk about
the second tool which is non-commutative
or matrix polynomial concentration
inequalities okay
so let me just first talk about
polynomial concentration inequalities
so what's the setup here
let's say you have
uh
epsilon which is chosen
uniformly at random
from one minus one to the n
so random plus one minus one string
and
i have a polynomial p
from
rn to r
let's say the constants term
no constant term
and what we are interested in is to show
some kind of concentration for the
polynomial p
evaluated at a random plus or minus 1
string
so
let me define the error function t
as
probability that p of x
f epsilon
epsilon
is
t times some parameter so what should i
put in here it should be the standard
deviation of the polynomial
so that's how you should scale things
and i'll write this
as
the variance of p raised to the power
half
and the variance of p or any polynomial
is just
the expectation of
so this is all standard
we write this as the max
so this ideally this probability should
be small so i am going to look at
and what do we know about it let's look
at some simple examples the classical
churn of bound
says that if your polynomial let me
write it down here
something
then you get the following error
function
so if p is just summation
a i epsilon i so that's a linear
function
then the deviation you get is
basically exponential and minus t
squared because of gaussian
concentration
and this has been known for a long time
there is another inequality which is
which comes from
hyper contractivity
that if p is a degree d polynomial
so you have a degree d polynomial
then the right concentration is
so it's exponential but you lose
a factor of d in the exponent of t
if put d equals one you just record the
old result so the variance of the
polynomial
oh no it doesn't yeah
because you're kind of normalized by it
and
there's a different generalization of
this which is somewhat recent but it's
it's also very powerful this is matrix
polynomials
so let me write this result this is due
to oliveira
from 2008
so instead of looking at just a linear
function on epsilon s
i'm going to take a sum of random
matrices
where the coefficients
are these epsilon x
there has to be some normalization you
haven't shown even for the trap
so the way i define the error function
already is removing the
so now i want to
make similar statements but where my
polynomial is
takes matrix is matrix valued
so think of a i
as a
d by d
symmetric
matrix
okay
and
now
let me just remove this absolute value
here
so
but now it's it's a little tricky what
should the variance be and what should
this inequality mean
well it's natural to guess what the
inequality should mean
and
so greater than for matrices is
in
the positive semi-definite ordering
so the definition of the variance is
still the same it's just the expectation
of p squared
and now the variance will be a d by d
matrix which is positive semi-definite
okay
and what we want is that the polynomial
be greater than the variance times some
factor t in the positive semi-definite
ordering
uh it's the square root in the
usual sense because this variance is a
positive semi-definite matrix you can
look at its square root so you get
positive
spectral non-inequality
so the original inequalities were stated
in terms of spectral norm but you can
easily prove the positivism and
different statement from the spectral
norm version
it's easy to go from one to the other
and for us it will be important that we
are working the positive semi-definite
ordering and it's kind of more natural i
think
no no it's spectral normal spectral long
is weaker but it's an easy reduction
so what do we know here this is uh
shown recently an error function now is
the same
as before almost
but
you lose a factor which is
the dimension
of the matrix
okay so if it's linear you get d times
exponential and minus t squared
and this factor of the dimension is
necessary in general
and it's an important factor
so if i have if i show you these three
things then the next question is or
should be what happens if p is a matrix
polynomial
so what if p
is
so what happens now
and
turns out that in our proof we actually
need such a tailbone and this is what we
show
so this is uh
oh i forgot to mention this don't tell
avi but this is joint work with uh
avi victorson
so this
is
he's watching you now
we shouldn't tell you it's a joke
so what we get is
so if you kind of by interpolation you
should lose this factor of d from the
linear case and you should have you have
this so kind of that's what we get
but there's a loss that we have
and this is
so the factor of dimension and this
exponential minus t to the 2 over d that
is necessary just from
these two this this and this
but we have an extraneous factor of n to
the d which we don't think is necessary
but our current proof does not show that
and for us it does not matter because
the dimension itself is uh
of the same order
so you're not losing much in the
tailbone for us
but ideally it should not be there
no no no
yeah
if the matrices commute then
you can probably do some other stuff
and this is a rich history behind even
this this linear case
the one i stated is utility it's exactly
is formulated like this by alder error
but there is a
work in banach space theory about
non-committed to kinchin inequalities
and you can deduce this from there and
that's where we have the term
non-communicative here
so in the remaining five minutes let me
just
say how ah
let me just define larger hierarchy and
say how these things appear
uh
so the formulation of laser hierarchy
that i'll use is the positive student
such framework it's easier to describe
and
the starting point for that is uh the
fundamental theorem of
algebraic geometry which is hilbert's
null standard science
so what does hilbers know still answer
say
so it says if i have some system of
polynomial equations let's say these are
when is the system of equations
it is infeasible if and only if
the idea
oh sorry complex numbers yeah yeah
that's important
so when is the system infeasible
infeasible
if and only if
the ideal of these polynomials contains
if there exists if and only if there
exists polynomials gi's such that if you
look at the sum f i g i you get one
okay and this immediately implies
infusibility and the conversation
is
real part of the theorem
this is great but
what if
i put rn here
so now i'm only looking for real
solutions which is often the case for us
and now this statement no longer holds
we can look at the polynomial x squared
plus one equals zero
that has no solutions but you cannot
generate one from that idea
and
there's a rich theory called real
algebraic geometry which says
essentially that this is the only
exception you can have
these are the only polynomials which
violate this
equality
is positive
so the system is infeasible if and only
if
the ideal contains a polynomial which
looks like one
plus a sum of squares of other
polynomials okay
and once again if you have such an
identity it is easy to show in
feasibility
okay
so this is great but
if you want to use this as some kind of
algorithm or a certification for
infeasibility it's not so nice because
these polynomials there's no bond on the
degree or the size
and what grigoriev
and
wallab chow
suggested was the following
see
let me abbreviate this as ps
our
proof system
so you want to prove the system is
infeasible but now you look for the same
identities like here but
you limit the degrees
of the polynomials
okay this is
f i times gi
it's just easier to write it this way
okay
so all the polynomials they are in the
identity should have degree less than or
equal to 2r okay and this is the proof
system
and this exactly
uh there's no bound
so you can say that it's at most n to
the r or something but uh we don't care
about that much
and they did this in 2001 and as it
turns out this is exactly or more or
less the same as lazer
uh
our ground
azare relaxations
okay
and this is the framework we will look
at now so this is the same as showing
lesser lower bounds or getting larger
algorithms
for a general class of problems there's
some technical conditions that this fis
must satisfy
like uh
they had to be bound there or some such
but for us they are those conditions
always hold and there this is just
equivalent
and
so let's see what the system of
equations is and how we can construct
such
uh show the non-existence of such
identities for clique
okay
so the equations for cliques are quite
natural so you have a graph g
and let's say a parameter
okay
so you have x i square minus x i is
equal to zero these are the boolean
axioms you want to force the solutions
to be billions
and
x i times x j is zero
if is not an edge
finally you want a condition on the size
of the click
so if this system of equations is
feasible this system of equations is
feasible if and only if the graph has a
clique of size
k
and what we would like to show now as
our main theorem to get a larger lower
bound
is that
there is no ps
positive students as refutation of this
island of this system of equations of
certain degree if the graph is random
drawn from g and half
again
so we want to show that there exists no
positive sense as refutations of a
certain degree for this system of
equations when the graph g is from g n
half
so how do you show that such
identities do not exist
so you exhibit a certificate
so showing
on existence
of refutations
how do you do it you just show you build
a map
a linear map
from
polynomials of
degree less than or equal to r
to reals
it's a linear mapping from polynomials
to real such that it has to satisfy
three conditions
so if you want to show non-existence of
degree r refutations
then you want
the map evaluated on anything in the
ideal of degree atmosphere to be zero
okay it should be non
trivial
so let me just say m of 1 is 1 and
finally
this is the most important condition
m of h squared should be non-negative if
degree of h is at most r
okay and once you have such a linear
mapping it's easy to show it
it follows immediately that there cannot
exist such refutations you'll apply m on
both sides you'd get 0 here and
something non-negative
positive here okay
and if you're coming from the larger
world this m exactly corresponds to a
good fractional solution
how do you show the existence of this m
and most often if you start with these
equations you initially work with these
two guys
and this enforces some
linear constraints on what this m should
be
you just you know try some few things
and you kind of this solution stares at
you okay
and for us the solution click case you
just do some simple arithmetic
this is a solution you get i'll just
write this down and i'll stop
off
so let me define
something called degree afterward
so you have a graph g and we are trying
to construct this mapping m okay
so if i have a subset of vertices i want
to generalize the notion of degree to
this subset of vertices and the
generalization we consider is the
following
number of clicks
of size
2r
okay
if i is a single vertex and r is one the
number of cliques of size two which
contain this vertex is just the usual
degree of the vertex right
and this is a generalization of the
notion of degree
and as it turns out you can define the
mapping m as follows
you can define it just for monomials and
and define it for monomials and then
extend it multilinearly to all
polynomials
and you should take it to be
proportional to the degree of the vertex
for that monomial by some scaling factor
let's ignore the scaling factor
where what's important is that you get
this degree
okay
and once you have this what you get
is uh you have to show a certain matrix
is positive semi-definite
so this satisfies this inequalities this
this kind of constraints this set of
constraints
but the real deal is ensuring that the
satisfies this constraint m of h squared
is non-negative
and there you can reduce it to showing
that certain matrix is positive
semi-definite
but the entries of the matrix are very
somewhat complicated they depend on
these degrees
okay and these themselves are random
but they're random in a bad way for us
because they're very correlated
okay
and that's where our theory this
association schemes and
non-communicative polynomial
concentration comes in
we can use these two to show that this
matrix is positive semi-definite
so even though these entries are random
and they're correlated you can
characterize the correlations as low
degree polynomial
and then use the theory of association
schemes to estimate the variance and
the expectation of this matrix
okay these matrices themselves don't
come from
no no if you look at the expectation of
this matrix which itself is a
complicated object to understand that
comes from association schemes and the
variance again
is a bit more complicated it takes some
careful combinatorics to actually
compute it we don't compute it but get
some estimates that also lies in the
association scheme but now we have to
compare these two matrices the
expectation versus the variance and that
we do because we can compute the
eigenvalues exactly and we know which
matrices are positive semi-definite
okay so that's where these two things
time
so let me stop there
so there's a strong analogy between uh
so i'm coming back to the very beginning
clicking so there is a very strong
analogy between
the
clicks in a random graph and so on and
and the
positive sub two moments of truth
so every tournament there is also a gap
we don't know there is a factor of four
between
what can be said about the existence of
a homogeneous subset
every graph on end vertices contains
indirect click of an anticlick on a half
log and a random is two logic and and
likewise in the tournament
it's very easy to show that in an
android experiment there is a transitive
sub component of login and the random
one doesn't have more than two locations
okay so i wonder
and and sometimes there is an analogy
and sometimes things are easier this
time and sometimes they're easier and
gentlemen
did any do you know i mean is anyone
looked at the planted
a
transitive sub tournament
if you take a random
tournament and you planting it a large
larger than
what you'd expect
i don't know that's a good question
i'm not aware of anything but that's a
good question
oh here uh
so we kind of cheat and we just use
induction and reduce it to the degree
one case here
so you can use induction
kind of on the degree of the polynomial
here so this can be done also for the
yeah
yeah yeah this is why you have to
swallow this yeah into the d yeah
exactly
and the linear case is very interesting
because i mean it's non-trivial it uses
the good it's simple but it uses a
golden thompson inequality and
it's nice
so there should be some non-trivial
thing going on and we kind of push it to
the
linear case
so that's one open problem try to get
this end to the d out here
and another open problem is to remove
the r squared
not for us uh not for us but i think uh
this statement itself should find other
applications i mean it's a polynomial
concentration inequality this has had a
lot of applications from the time it
came out so naturally